[Musique]
nous voilà arrivés nounours à l'eau
bonsoir nos amis vous voyez nous sommes
vite revenu alors nounours tu descends
voir nicolas et pimprenelle ils
t'attendent yes bon on de minutes
aïe aïe mon et shan et aux eaux ni pas
preneur t'es sûr qu'il faut pas oublier
mais il arrive chez l'auteur et l'eau on
t'attendait nord on est tellement
content que tu reviennes qu'on voudrait
bien passer la ronde du routier avec toi
tu veux bien mais mon parapluie
bonjour dans l'onglet on te donnera
notre de parapluies un qui pense la
ronde du rosier bonne nuit jantes le
maine nous on va se coucher
[Musique]
une palpitante
on
et moi je dire aux petits marchands de
sable qu'il faut plutôt emmené en
angleterre il en fut un bruit là bas
qu'elle s'en va je veux mais tu te rends
compte que tu nous a rapporté d'anglet
et ben c'est pas grand chose à la
prochaine fois que j'irai là non ça
suffit comme ça le nom de nuit là
j'éteins la lumière
faites de beaux rêves goodbye partout
bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
à demain les enfants
alors mr nounours ready ne paraît plus
anglais patron je vous en prie mes deux
petits amis sont très fâchés contre
l'angleterre ne sait normal nous nours
ils n'y sont jamais allés
et ils ne le comprennent pas il veut la
france on y va en route
dans nuit les enfants de boer
[Musique]
on
vous
[Musique]